herzlich Willkommen zu Phönix vor Ort
unsere Themen heute Nachmittag das
Bundeskabinett hat den Weiterbetrieb der
drei verbleibenden deutschen
Atomkraftwerke bis Mitte April kommenden
jahresgebilligt und damit die Anordnung
von Kanzler Scholz umgesetzt die
Energiekrise ist auch Thema auf EU-Ebene
die EU-Kommission hatte gestern einen
Plan vorgelegt um Energiekosten zu
senken und die Versorgungssicherheit zu
gewährleisten dazu später mehr am
Nachmittag jetzt aber erstmal nach
Berlin in den Deutschen Bundestag die
Sitzungswoche beginnt heute mit einer
Befragung der Bundesregierung
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing stellt
sich den Fragen der Abgeordneten und
Katharina küenes vor Ort und hat mehr
für uns und an dieser Stelle
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 ja und hier hat
Bundestagspräsidenten Bärbel Bass schon
die Sitzung eröffnet hier wird noch kurz
über die
Tagesordnung informiert die hat sich ein
bisschen geändert ich heute zum Beispiel
noch eine Aktuelle Stunde ja passend zur
Ausweitung des energieangebots und dann
kommen wir hier aber gleich zur
Befragung der Bundesregierung wie schon
eben erwähnt mit Bundesverkehrsminister
Volker Wissing da gibt es ja auch vieles
aktuelles was die Abgeordneten
interessiert besonders in den
Schlagzeilen natürlich einen
Nachfolgeregelung zum neuen euro-ticket
auf diese gab es vergangenen Donnerstag
eine Einigung für 49 Euro soll es im
Idealfall ab dem 1 Januar möglich sein
den Nahverkehr in ganz Deutschland zu
nutzen allerdings ist noch immer nicht
ganz klar wie das finanziert werden soll
wie viel trägt der Bund wie viel die
Länder das dürfte hier auch noch für
Gesprächsstoff sorgen und natürlich gab
es auch daran Kritik ob 49 Euro wirklich
für diejenigen dann auch ein Angebot ist
sowieso schon sparen müssen in dieser
Krisenzeit die digitalstrategie dürfte
ein Thema sein oder zum Beispiel auch ob
die Infrastruktur wie die Bahn gefährdet
ist als Angriffsziel also werden wir
schauen Volker Wissing wird hier als
erstes ein Statement halten fünf Minuten
hat er Zeit für seine Erklärung
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mehr Fortschritt Wagen mit
diesem Versprechen sind wir vor noch
nicht mal einem Jahr angetreten heute
kann ich sagen wir halten unser
Versprechen
sowohl in der Digitalisierung als auch
bei der Mobilität haben wir
entscheidende Weichen gestellt und
kommen trotz der schwierigen Bedingungen
anlässlich des ukraine-krieges enorm gut
voran beispielsweise
digitalstrategie und Gigabit Strategie
beides zusammen ermöglicht Deutschland
endlich den umfassenden digitalen
Aufbruch auf den alle schon so lange
warten den Personalausweis beantragen
einen neuen Wohnort mitteilen oder ein
neues Unternehmen anmelden das alles
soll künftig in wenigen Minuten online
zu erledigen sein am besten mit dem
Smartphone vom eigenen Sofa aus bis 2025
soll zumindest die Hälfte aller
Anschlüsse in Deutschland mit Glasfaser
versorgt sein und außerdem sollen alle
am Mobilfunk bis 2026 drahtlose Sprach-
und Datendienste verlässlich
flächendeckend nutzen können
wenn klar ist Homeoffice Streaming im
ICE und Empfang auf der Berghütte alles
muss endlich auch in Deutschland
problemlos möglich sein oder nehmen wir
den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr 52
Millionen Menschen haben in diesem
Sommer ja gesagt Sie haben ja gesagt zum
ÖPNV und das 9 euro-ticket erworben
hinzu kommen 10 Millionen Menschen die
den ÖPNV ohnehin bereits im Abo nutzen
das ist sensationell und ein klares
Signal es zeigt die Menschen sind bereit
Neues auszuprobieren und Dinge anders zu
machen als gewohnt wenn wir es Ihnen
einfach machen genau das war das
Erfolgsgeheimnis dieses Tickets die
Einfachheit einmal kaufen und dann
losfahren ohne Nachdenken ohne sich mit
Waben und komplizierten Tarifstrukturen
auseinandersetzen zu müssen das hat
überzeugt mir noch als der Preis und
deshalb freue ich mich das Bund und
Länder fest entschlossen sind so schnell
wie möglich einen Nachfolge Lösung für
dieses dicke zu schaffen wir müssen den
Schwung aus dem Sommer nutzen der
öffentliche Personennahverkehr
und die Schiene insgesamt sie gehören zu
den ganz zentralen Elementen einer
modernen nachhaltigen Mobilität sie
bündeln Verkehre entlasten
straßenschonend Klima und Umwelt und
deshalb werden wir zum Beispiel auch bei
der Schiene die wichtigen Korridore
generalsanieren das heißt Schritt für
Schritt wird sich die Bahn in auf ihren
hoch belasteten Strecken darum kümmern
dass auf einen Schlag ein rundum Upgrade
erfolgt also statt wie bisher üblich bei
einer Strecke erst die Weichen
auszutauschen in einem halben Jahr die
Oberleitung zu erneuern im folgenden
Jahr die Schwellen und dann am Bahnhof
zu arbeiten soll künftig alles auf
einmal erledigt werden in einem einzigen
Zeitfenster inklusive Modernisierung der
Stellwerke nach so einer
Generalsanierung haben wir dort dann
jahrelang freie Fahrt Fortschritt das
ist ein Paradigmenwechsel von dem
Personenverkehr und Güterverkehr
gleichermaßen profitieren oder nehmen
Sie den Masterplan laderinfrastruktur 2
den das Kabinett heute beschlossen hat
mit 68 Maßnahmen bringen wir die
Infrastruktur so voran dass sie dem
Hochlauf der Elektromobilität gerecht
wird
auch unser Beschleunigungsgesetz dass
wir im Rahmen des herbstpakets der
Bundesregierung zur
planungsbeschleunigung demnächst
vorlegen werden greifen wir genau die
richtigen Themen auf die die Leute in
Deutschland von uns erwarten oder nehmen
Sie das brückenprogramm mit dem wir
weniger als in zehn Jahren ein
zusammenhängendes Kernnetz von besonders
wichtigen autobahnenabschnitten
durchgängig mit leistungsfähigen Brücken
herrichten wollen statt 200 künftig 400
pro Jahr im Sanierungsprogramm oder
nehmen Sie sichere Radwege Infrastruktur
uns ist es gelungen was Länder und
Kommunen schon lange fordern nämlich die
Verstetigung der
Fördermittel für den Radverkehr in
Deutschland damit haben Länder und
Kommunen endlich die Planung sondern
finanzierungsperspektive die Sie
benötigen um wirklich anzupacken sie
sehen
noch an Fortschritt ich könnte jetzt
weitermachen aber sie sollen die
Möglichkeiten haben Fragen zu stellen
und deswegen möchte ich es an dieser
Stelle mit dem eingangstatement frau
Präsidentin verwenden lassen vielen Dank
vielen Dank wir beginnen die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen des Bundesministers Herrn
Dr Volker Wissing und zum
Geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung und
allgemeinen Fragen das Wort hat zuerst
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege
Ulrich lange
sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister
27,5% des Energiebedarfs
braucht der Verkehrssektor
jetzt haben sie sich diese Woche
verständigt oder sie wurden verständigt
bei der
laufzeit-diskussion der AKWs
10% laut ihrem Staatssekretär teurer
fährt die Bahn mit Kernenergie
ihr koalitionskollege Jürgen Trittin
wirft ihnen gestern im Deutschlandfunk
Wortbruch vor dass es beim Thema Sektor
Ziele nach dem Klimaschutzgesetz
insbesondere im Verkehrsbereich exakt
die gleiche
Blockadehaltung seitens der FDP gebe
Herr Minister
blockieren sie klimagerechte Mobilität
nein Herr Kollege im Gegenteil wir
sorgen dafür dass in Deutschland das was
lange versprochen worden ist umgesetzt
wird nämlich nachhaltige
Energieerzeugung
vorangebracht wird und gleichzeitig
müssen wir natürlich auf die
gegenwärtigen Herausforderungen des
ukrainekrieges reagieren und
selbstverständlich tut die
Bundesregierung zunächst einmal alles
damit die Energieversorgung in den
nächsten Monaten über diesen schwierigen
Winter hinweg gesichert bleibt das ist
die vorrangige Aufgabe der wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam stellen und dass das keine
einfachen Fragen sind das versteht sich
von selbst aber dass die Bundesregierung
klare Ziele hat und auch klare Wege
definiert hat wie sie diese Ziele
erreicht dass wissen alle und ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass wir mit einer
stabilen Energieversorgung in der
sicheren Energieversorgung
können und natürlich bleiben die
Herausforderungen aufgrund des
ukrainekrieges groß aber die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Bundesregierung
ist noch größer
öffne eine Nachfrage stellen
ich stelle auch gerne eine Nachfrage
Herr Minister glauben Sie wirklich dass
sie dabei in der Koalition an einem
Strang ziehen ich denke an das Interview
von Toni Hofreiter gestern im NTV
Frühstart da wirft er ihnen vor ein
Tempolimit wäre sinnvoll aber das
blockiert die FDP wie wollen sie
überhaupt noch Ideologie frei sich für
faire Energiepreise im Verkehrssektor
einsetzen
Herr Kollege dass die Bundesregierung
ideologiefrei zu arbeiten versteht das
glaube ich haben alle inzwischen gemerkt
und dass wir
in unserer Gesellschaft und auch in
diesem Hohen Haus
unterschiedliche Positionen diskutieren
und dass das auch die Fraktionen
innerhalb einer
Koalitionsregierung tun das ist das
große Glück parlamentarischer
Demokratien und das Ringen um die beste
Lösung setzt ja immer voraus dass
unterschiedliche Positionen
unterschiedliche Blickwinkel
ausgesprochen werden und diskutiert
werden das ist der Kollege kein Problem
sondern eine Chance für eine Demokratie
ich würde sagen es ist unsere Stärke es
wird nur dann zum Problem wenn eine
Regierung dadurch handlungsunfähig wird
und Sie können sicher sein das wird bei
dieser Bundesregierung nicht passieren
[Applaus]
genau jetzt zeigen ganz viele auf ich
wollte gerade eröffnen jetzt ist Zeit
für die Nachfragen ich weise noch mal
darauf hin zum Thema obwohl das Thema
sehr breit gefasst war versuche ich es
hinzubekommen in der Frage und vor allen
Dingen bitte auf die Zeit achten der
rote Balken dass die Zeiten eingehalten
werden wir notieren gleich die die
nachfragenden Kollegen zuerst hat das
Wort aus der afd-fraktion Frau von
Storch
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister sie haben gerade gesagt dass
die Energiesicherheit jetzt
gewährleistet ist weil sie ja
beschlossen hätten drei AKWs bis April
nächsten Jahres am Wand zu lassen
faktisch hat die Regierung das Gegenteil
beschlossen sie haben nämlich den
finalen Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie
komplett zum nächsten Jahr beschlossen
und ich würde sie vor dem Hintergrund
gerne fragen wie Sie uns erklären wollen
dass sie im Nachgang nach April 24
nächsten Jahres 23 Entschuldigung die
Energiesicherheit grundlastfähig
gewährleisten wollen wo sie doch jetzt
gerade beschlossen haben final aus der
Atom- und Kernenergie auszusteigen
Frau Kollegin die versorgen sich halt
dem Energiebereich beruht nicht auf
einer einzelnen Maßnahme deswegen habe
ich mich auch nicht so ausgedrückt wie
sie mich zitiert haben ich habe nicht
gesagt die Energieversorgung ist sicher
weil wir die Kernkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen sondern sie
Energieversorgung ist sicher wegen
dieser und vieler anderer Maßnahmen
beispielsweise auch dem Einsatz von
Kohlekraftwerken und viele mehr es ist
die Summe der energiepolitischen
Maßnahmen die die Bundesregierung
ergriffen hat die uns eine
Versorgungssicherheit im Energiebereich
liefert und wir müssen ja immer zwei
Dinge im Blick haben einmal die
Versorgungssicherheit der Bevölkerung
mit Energie und natürlich auch die
Energiepreisentwicklung und deswegen ist
das ein kompliziertes Konstrukt und
wie ich finde sehr ausgewogen was die
Bundesregierung hier auf den Weg
gebracht hat wir tun alles um
Energiepreise zu stabilisieren und
selbstverständlich auch alles was in
unseren Möglichkeiten liegt um die
Energieversorgung zu sichern sie dürfen
eine Nachfrage stellen ja
und zwar hatte gesagt
der Energieträger und haben angesprochen
Kohle ich nehme noch mal Flüssiggas dazu
dann sagen Sie mir doch bitte für wie
viele Kohlekraftwerke sie nunmehr eine
verlängerte Laufzeit zulassen werden so
dass die Kohlekraftwerke in der Tat in
Summe in Mehrzahl ans Netz gehen können
und wie viele Kubikmeter
Flüssiggas die schon kontrahiert haben
um die entstehende Lücke an diesen
beiden Stellen zu fassen sie sprechen
immer von einer Vielzahl von Maßnahmen
von vielen Einzelmaßnahmen aber werden
sie doch mal bitte konkret wie viele
Kohlekraftwerke gehen ans Netz und wie
viel Flüssigkeit haben sie kontrahiert
Frau Kolleginnen wenn ich von der Summe
der Maßnahmen spreche dann sind es die
Dinge die sie kennen deswegen weiß ich
gar nicht warum sie danach fragen es ist
zum einen die Versorgung mit mit mit
Energie aus Gas das ist die Versorgung
mit Energie aus Kohle die wir brauchen
auch wenn sich das natürlich nicht
hinsichtlich unserer CO2-Minderungsziele
positiv auswirkt und natürlich nutzen
wir auch noch planenergie und in der
Summe schaffen wir damit eine sichere
Energieversorgung und die der Einsatz
der jeweiligen Energieträger ist nicht
trivial weil wir einerseits wissen wir
haben nicht unendlich Gas zur Verfügung
andererseits ist diese Veränderung bei
den Kernkraftwerken auch eine
Herausforderung auch in technischer
Hinsicht weil man sich ja anders
vorbereitet hatte und dass die Kohle
angeht sind wir natürlich hier auch
unter einem großen Herausforderung was
die logistischen Anforderungen angeht
aber die Summe der Maßnahmen zeigt die
Bundesregierung hat hier einen sehr
richtigen Weg eingeschlagen
Herr Minister achten Sie auch auf die
Antwort Zeit
dann komme ich zur nächsten Nachfrage
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege
dont
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin haben
Minister die aktuellen Preissteigerungen
bei Diesel oder auch AdBlue sind für
viele Bus und Taxiunternehmen im Land
existenzbedrohend ohne die haben wir
aber keine Chance den ÖPNV aufrecht zu
erhalten und dort noch zu steigern
bislang haben diese Unternehmen
keinerlei Hilfen durch die
Bundesregierung bekommen überhalb
zweieinhalbtausend mittelständische
Busunternehmen und 20.000
Taxiunternehmen werden von der Regierung
bislang im Stich gelassen jetzt fordern
die Länder an 1,65 Milliarden Euro für
22 und nochmal für 2023 an
regulierungsmitteln für diesen Zweck
halten sie das zur gerechtfertigt und
werden sie den Unternehmen helfen
zunächst einmal Herr Kollege hat die
Bundesregierung hier schon sehr viel
geholfen und zwar haben wir gemeinsam
mit den Ländern ein paritätisch
finanzierten corona-rettungsschirm für
den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr auf
den Weg gebracht deswegen wundere ich
mich dass sie sagen für die Unternehmen
im Busbereich ist nichts getan worden
und die Länder
sprechen gegenwärtig mit dem Bund über
die Erhöhung der Regionalisierungsmittel
das haben wir unlängst jetzt bei der
Verkehrsministerkonferenz in Bremerhaven
auch getan
wir sind dort nicht zu einer Einigung
gekommen die Länder möchten das in der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz klären dort
wird das in Kürze stattfinden und den
Beratungen der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz kann ich
daher heute nicht vorgreifen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
ist sie wundern sich dass das Geld nicht
angekommen ist dass ich insofern
verwunderlich weil gerade die
eigenwirtschaftlichen Verkehre die von
Unternehmern in unserem Land auf eigene
Rechnung angebracht werden eben von
diesen Geldern beispielsweise überhaupt
nichts gesehen haben
weil es eben an einer allgemeinen
Vorschrift fehlt in vielen Ländern haben
sie vor damit Gelder dann zukünftig dort
ankommen bundesweit für solch eine
allgemeine Vorschrift einzutreten
zunächst einmal Herr Kollege ist der
öffentliche Personennahverkehr keine
Bundes sondern eine Landesaufgabe und
das gilt insbesondere für die
Busverkehre
deswegen
wundere ich mich dass Sie diese
Kostenforderung so einseitig an den Bund
richten ich diskutiere mit den Ländern
seit meinem Amtsantritt über die Frage
wie können wir diese ÖPNV Finanzierung
die ja vom Bund begleitet wird nach der
Verfassung durch ein Teil des
Steueraufkommens wie können wir die
besser strukturieren wir haben deshalb
auf meinen Betreiben hin schon im
Februar eine Arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt
die jetzt ein Zwischenergebnis vorgelegt
hat wie wir das künftig besser machen
können das Zwischenergebnis konnten wir
in Bremerhaven nicht beraten oder
konnten die Länder nicht beraten bei der
nächsten VMK soll das stattfinden und
dann sind wir sicherlich ein Schritt
weiter
wir sind immer noch bei der bei den
Nachfragen zur ursprünglich gestellten
Frage möchte nur darauf hinweisen und
jetzt hat das Wort der Kollege aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ich glaube der Kollege
Müller
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Herr
Minister angesichts der Preisentwicklung
beim büroöl Ende Februar hatten wir
einen Preis pro Barrel von 130 Dollar
der liegt jetzt bei 90 Dollar da machen
in der Zeit ihrer Regierung die
Mineralölkonzerne Rekordgewinne was
wollen Sie konkret tun damit dieser
unhaltbare Zustand nicht weiter anhält
und gerade jetzt die Mineral die
Mineralölkonzerne Rekordgewinne
einfahren während die Verbraucher
insbesondere im ländlichen Raum nicht
unter diesen nicht nachvollziehbaren
Energiepreisen zu leiden haben
sehr gute Frage gut Herr Kollege die
Bundesregierung hat durch verschiedene
entlastungspakete insbesondere auf die
Energiepreisentwicklung reagiert und wir
hatten im Sommer ja auch eine Absenkung
der Kosten für
Kraftstoffe durch entsprechende
Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung auf den
Weg gebracht die wir auch noch mit
Energiespar Anreizen begleitet haben
insgesamt nimmt die Bundesregierung das
Thema Energiepreisentwicklung sehr ernst
und steuert konsequent dagegen
Rasenmäher sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen
dass sie zur Entlastung der Pendlerinnen
und Pendler jetzt im Winter kein
annehmbares Konzept dem Land anbieten
können nein denn die Bundesregierung hat
gerade ein neues Entlastungspaket auf
den Weg gebracht dass ich an die gesamte
Gesellschaft richtet und dieses
Entlastungspaket befindet sich in der
Umsetzung und insofern sind wir mit
jetzt hier dem dem nächsten
entlastungsschritt so vorbereitet dass
für alle Teile der Gesellschaft
passgenaue Maßnahmen gefunden werden
ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass ich
noch eine zahlreiche Anzahl an
Nachfragen habe ich lasse jetzt noch
drei zu
nee ich weiß gar nicht aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion war da noch jemand
gerade oder nicht dass ich jemand
übersehen habe
dann habe ich jetzt aus der SPD-Fraktion
die Kollegin Dorothee Martin
ist wir sind noch im nachfrageverfahren
dann
Christian schreiner
sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister dieses
Thema Versorgungssicherheit wurde
angesprochen ein wichtiges Element ist
die Kohle es wurde für eine
bevorrichtigung der kohlezüge auf der
Schiene gesorgt wenn sie uns da
konkretere Einschätzung dazu geben
können wenn wir es ja dankbar vielen
Dank
ja Kollege die bevor rechtung der Kohle
ist notwendig weil sie sicherstellen
muss dass wir eine stabile
Energieversorgung haben und die Schiene
ist auf Stromversorgung angewiesen wir
haben deswegen die rechtlichen
Voraussetzungen dafür geschaffen dass im
Zweifel
kohle-züge Vorrang haben gleichzeitig
haben wir zusätzliche Waggons ertüchtigt
die bereits im ausrangiert waren die
wurden technisch aufgerüstet und wieder
in Betrieb genommen so dass wir von 900
Waggons die im Betrieb waren inzwischen
auf 200 Entschuldigung auf 2000
aufstocken konnten damit haben wir eine
maximale Verfügbarkeit geschaffen mehr
Waggons haben wir nicht aber damit
können wir zusammen mit dem
prioritätsregeln sicherstellen dass die
Kohle Transporte vorrangig in den in den
Kraftwerken ankommen
[Applaus]
letzte Nachfrage
Herr lindert aus der FDP-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Bundesminister
unzweifelhaft ihr sind ja die Nachfragen
jetzt zur Energie aufgekommen
Unfallverlauf gehört ja auch der Ausbau
und die Beschleunigung der
Energieinfrastruktur dazu welche
parallelen können Sie denn da ziehen die
planungsbeschleunigung auch im
Verkehrsbereich voranzutreiben
Herr Kollege insgesamt müssen wir bei
Planung schneller werden wir sehen dass
die Auswirkungen des Krieges uns vor so
große Herausforderungen stellen dass wir
mit Schema F mit Standard nicht mehr
schnell genug reagieren können wir haben
das bei den LNG Terminals gesehen und
sehen auch bei anderen Bereichen dass
wir schneller reagieren müssen wir
wollen deshalb mit einem weiteren
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz eine ganze
Reihe von Maßnahmen auf den Weg bringen
um unsere Logistikketten zu sichern um
Infrastruktur schneller zu ertüchtigen
um Klimaschutzziele erreichen zu können
wir haben beispielsweise bereits die
Planungs die Planungszeiten bei Raum
Ordnungsverfahren auf 7 Monate begrenzt
wir wollen bei Trans europäischen Netzen
maximal vier Jahre Planungszeit haben um
die Dinge umzusetzen das Ziel der
Bundesregierung ist die Planungszeiten
in Deutschland zu halbieren und dazu
gehört deine ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen
auch building Information modeling
beispielsweise
nutzen damit kann man 20% Planungszeiten
einsparen wir haben schon viel vorgelegt
wir haben aber auch noch viel vor in
diesem Bereich in den nächsten Monaten
ich gehe weiter in die Fragerunde der
angemeldeten fragestellerinnen und
Fragesteller und jetzt hat das Wort aus
der SPD-Fraktion die Kollegin Dorothee
Martin
vielen Dank Herr Minister sie haben in
ihren einführenden Worten ja schon auf
einige wichtige Verkehrsträger
hingewiesen ich möchte meinen Fokus
heute in der Frage auf die Wasserstraße
legen denn gerade wenn wir über
Erreichung von Klimazielen im Verkehr
sprechen ist die Wasserstraße auch neben
der Schiene der ganz entscheidende
Verkehrsträger wir brauchen mehr
Verlagerung vom Güterverkehr von der
Straße gerade auch um unsere
Wasserstraßen wir sehen aber auch dass
die Wasserstraßen gerade besonders im
Fokus sind aufgrund der international
sehr angespannter Lieferketten und auch
Fragen durchaus der
Versorgungssicherheit und wir sehen dass
wir durchaus auch ein Sanierungsstau
haben der aufgehoben werden muss daher
meine Frage wie sie in ihre Konzepte
ihre Strategien auch zu Finanzierung und
zur Aufhebung dieses sanierungsstausen
zu Ertüchtigung unserer Wasserstraßen
aus vielen Dank Herr Frau Kollegin die
Wasserstraße ist in der Tat ein enorm
wichtiger
Verkehrsträger wir können bestimmte
Mengen bestimmte Rohstoffe kaum besser
transportieren als über die Wasserstraße
das gilt auch für Kohle gilt aber für
viele andere Rohstoffe die in großer
Menge transportiert werden müssen in
Fabriken beispielsweise deswegen ist die
Ertüchtigung unserer Wasserstraßen für
uns eine ganz wichtige und zentrale
Aufgabe was wir hier allerdings
vorgefunden haben bei Regierungsantritt
ist ein enormer Sanierungsstau bei
wären etwa und Schleusen deswegen ist
immer ganz wichtig dass wir beides im im
Blick haben einerseits den
Sanierungsstau der hinterlassen worden
ist abarbeiten denn ein Ausfall von
Schleusen bedeutet immer auch ein Stopp
der der der
Binnenschifffahrt und gleichzeitig
müssen wir unsere Wasserstraßen ausbauen
etwa den reinen vertiefen oder auch
andere Wasserstraßen
wir fahren deswegen ein Konzept das
sicherstellt dass die Infrastruktur
intakt bleibt saniert wird und
bauen gleichzeitig aus wo immer wir das
aufgrund der Möglichkeiten des
Bundeshaushalts auch leisten können
ist die dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
eine kurze Nachfrage oder noch mal eine
Präzisierung meiner Frage jegliche
ausbauen Modernisierung von
Infrastruktur braucht gutes Personal das
haben wir nicht nur bei der Wasserstraße
vielleicht dort konkret aber auch noch
mal meine Frage wie ist ihr Konzept auch
zur
Nachwuchskräfte Sicherung zur
Fachkräftesicherung im Bereich auch der
Infrastruktur dankeschön das Thema
Fachkräfte Sicherung ist eines der
vorrangigsten die Bundesregierung hat
deswegen eine gemeinsame
fachkräftestrategie entwickelt ich habe
für mein Haus aber entschieden dass mir
das nicht ausreicht weil ich natürlich
ein sehr großen personalkörper habe
insbesondere etwa Wasser und
Schifffahrtsverwaltung und deswegen habe
ich zusätzlich zur zur
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
insgesamt auch eine eigene spezifisch
auf die den Mobilitätssektor
zugeschnittene Strategie vorangebracht
wir hatten unlängst ein Fachkräfte wo
wir uns ganz konkret mit der Frage
beschäftigt haben was können wir denn
speziell im Mobilitätsbereich tun um
Fachkräfte zu sichern und wir haben eine
ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen identifiziert
die wir umsetzen wollen und natürlich
werben wir insbesondere für unsere
Ausbildungsberufe etwa die Wasserbauer
die wir so dringend brauchen in unserer
Wasser und Schifffahrtsverwaltung
wir sind beim Thema Wasserstraßen und
die erste Nachfrage
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen der Kollege
hier vorne
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich möchte
die Frage etwas weiten und zwar sie
haben selber die höheren Baukosten die
Knappen Baustoffe aber auch den hohen
Sanierungsbedarf nicht nur bei der
Wasserstraße schon angesprochen das kann
man ja auch denken auf die Schiene auf
die Straße insgesamt und daraus folgen
ja dann ein paar Fragen insbesondere was
die Ausbauvorhaben des Bedarfs der
bedarfsplänestraße Schiene Wasserstraße
angeht und da wollte ich die allgemeine
Frage stellen wie da die ja dann
wahrscheinlich notwendig also vor diesem
Hintergrund notwendige Priorisierung
erfolgen soll welche Gedanken ist da in
ihrem Haus und auch von ihnen gibt und
da ganz insbesondere in meinem Wissen
weg von der Wasserstraße auch beim
Straßenbereich wieder Neubauvorhaben von
Autobahnen zum Beispiel A100 A20 in
diesem Kontext auch noch mal priorisiert
oder eben gerade runter priorisiert
werden
ja ja Herr Kollege Gerber sie haben
vollkommen recht wenn die Dinge knapp
sind ist die Frage der richtigen
Priorisierung die
hohe politische Kunst und deswegen
brauchen wir um diese Priorisierung
vorzunehmen
Fakten wir brauchen wissen und dieses
Wissen holen wir uns indem wir jetzt
gegenwärtig einen Gutachten erstellen
lassen dass uns hilft eine Bedarfsplan
Überprüfung des Bundesverkehrswegeplans
vorzunehmen
anhand dieser Bedarfsplan Überprüfungen
können wir dann unter Berücksichtigung
der verkehrsbedarfe identifizieren was
prioritär gemacht werden muss um
Mobilität Logistik Ketten und natürlich
auch die Erreichung unserer
Klimaschutzziele sicherzustellen und
dabei werden natürlich auch die Projekte
im Einzelnen überprüft dieses über diese
Überprüfung ist aber nicht abgeschlossen
so dass ich jetzt den Verfahren
vorgreifen kann
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stehen stellen
und stellen vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
ja dann möchte ich nachfragen und zwar
vor diesem Hintergrund der Knappheiten
und wenn man dann politisch hier auch
Priorität hinsetzen kann gehen geben sie
da Vorgaben in ihr Haus zum einen und
zum anderen es gibt ja an vielen Stellen
auch Widerstände gegen Projekte aus dem
verkehrsinfrastrukturbereich wird das
dann jetzt auch jenseits der Bedarfsplan
Überprüfung mit herangezogen sodass wir
nicht an der Stelle vor Gerichten und
ähnliches versanden sondern eben die
Projekte die ja geeint oder zumindest
gesellschaftlich hoch anerkannt sind ihm
dann vorgezogen werden
ja Herr Kollege ich gebe Vorgaben in
mein Haus sogar sehr präzise ich habe
beispielsweise als es um die
Brückensanierung ging klar gesagt dass
die
sanierungsbedürftigen Brücken anders
identifiziert werden müssen mit mehr
Präzision etwa indem man den
Traglastindex zugrunde liegt und nicht
nur von außen schaut also zu
identifizieren was muss zuerst gemacht
werden ist genau die entscheidende Frage
und natürlich gibt es Widerstände gegen
einzelne Infrastrukturprojekte und wir
sind gut beraten wenn wir die
Priorisierung vornehmen dass wir sie
auch mit einem breiten Dialogprozess
begleiten das wollen wir tun wir wollen
noch in diesem Jahr wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen mit einem
Dialogprozess starten um auch
Transparenz zu schaffen für die
abwägungsprozesse die am Ende zur
richtigen Priorisierung führen sollen
nächste Nachfrage zum Thema aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege Schreiner
müsste das sein
ja Herr Minister Wissing vielen Dank für
ihre Beantwortung aber sie haben jetzt
Plädoyer für die Wasserstraßen in
Deutschland gehalten wie erklären sie
sich denn die Kürzungen eben den
aktuellen Haushaltsberatungen ihrer
Koalitionsfraktionen von 350 Millionen
Euro für den Ausbau der Wasserstraßen in
unserem Land und was bedeutet das
konkret für die neckarschleusen in
Baden-Württemberg ich erkläre mir die
Kürzungen damit dass die Haushaltsmittel
knapp sind und wir natürlich auch jetzt
bei der Verteilung der Haushaltsmittel
Priorisierungen treffen müssen ich bin
als
Bundesminister für digitales und Verkehr
sehr bemüht dass wir eine ausreichende
Finanzierung auch für die
Wasserstraßen bekommen und wir sind ja
nicht am Ende der Haushaltsberatung
sondern sind noch in den laufenden
Haushaltsberatungen und führen
konstruktive Gespräche um das zu
erreichen was mir am Herzen liegt und
hoffe auch auf eine breite Unterstützung
dieses Hauses und was die
neckarschleusen angeht so würde ich mir
wünschen dass ich sie nicht in einem so
schlechten Zustand übergeben bekommen
hätte wie das tatsächlich der Fall ist
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen Herr
Minister ist Ihnen bekannt dass seit
2007 das Land Baden-Württemberg 15
Stellen finanziert um den Ausbau der
neckarschleusen auf 135 Meter zu
unterstützen und ist ihnen auch bekannt
dass die Landesregierung fahren
Baden-Württemberg zu denen ja auch der
grüne Teil diese Koalition gehört sich
vehement für den Weiterbau einsetzen und
wie antworten Sie auf diese Forderung
aus Baden-Württemberg
ich bin Herr Kollege in einem sehr guten
Dialog mit der
baden-württembergischen Landesregierung
ich habe auch vor Ort mit
Wirtschaftsvertretern
Wirtschaftsvertretern gesprochen ich bin
mir darüber im Klaren wie wichtig die
neckarschifffahrt ist und ich werde
alles tun um die Bemühungen der Akteure
vor Ort zu unterstützen dass auch die
Schleusen verlängert werden wir müssen
nur leider einen großen Sanierungsstau
in zur Kenntnis nehmen und wir haben die
Situation dass man die neckarschleusen
so hat verkommen lassen dass man
Priorität jetzt dafür sorgen muss dass
sie nicht ausfallen und die Schifffahrt
auf dem Neckar zum Liegen kommt aber
gleichzeitig unterstütze ich auch den
weiteren Ausbau weil die
Binnenschifffahrt mir wirklich ein sehr
wichtiges Anliegen ist
ich sage jetzt schon voraus da ich noch
ein zwei drei vier fünf sechs Nachfragen
habe so kommen wir nicht durch es tut
mir leid ich werde jetzt noch ein paar
dran nehmen und dann werde ich zur
nächsten angemeldeten Fragen übergehen
jetzt ist aber dran aus der afd-fraktion
der Herr Spaniel
ich darf aber darauf hinweisen dass ich
einen Doktortitel erworben habe anders
als viele Entschuldigung Herr Doktor
Spanien ja muss man ja auch mal drüber
reden ist ja nicht selbstverständlich in
diesem Haus ja Herr Verkehrsminister sie
haben ja gerade explizit ausgeführt sie
haben ja gerade explizit ausgeführt dass
es sich für die Vertiefung des Rheins
eingesetzt haben und das auch diese
Maßnahmen dazu dass sie die befürworten
das wäre ja ein wesentlichen das
Ausbaggern
haben Sie Ihre Antwort eigentlich mit
der nordrhein-westfälischen
Landesregierung abgestimmt weil der
nordrhein-westfälische Umweltminister
Oliver Krischer von den Grünen hat
gerade in einem Gespräch mit der
Rheinischen Post eine Absage erteilt für
die reinvertiefung er fordert hingegen
zusätzliches Geld für Schiffe mit
geringerem Tiefgang wie ist denn jetzt
die Haltung der Bundesregierung zur
reinvertiefung und wie gehen sie um mit
einem ja Verkehrsminister in einem Land
das offensichtlich gewillt ist den Rhein
als Wasserstraße dann deutlich
einschränken als europäische
Wasserstraße und damit natürlich auch
hier unsere Infrastruktur bewusst zu
limitieren wie verhalten sich als
Bundesministerium dazu
die ablageoptimierung des Rheins ist
eines der wichtigsten
Infrastrukturprojekte im
Bundesverkehrswegeplan es hat ein Nutzen
Kostenverhältnis von nahezu 30 deswegen
arbeitet die Wasser- und
Schifffahrtsverwaltung auf meinen
Anweisungen hin mit Hochtouren daran
dieses Projekt voranzutreiben ich habe
dafür gesorgt dass ausreichend Personal
hier zur Verfügung steht gleichzeitig
habe ich veranlasst dass eine
beschleunigungskommission eingesetzt
wird in der alle Akteure auch
Industrievertreter beteiligt werden um
Vorschläge zur Beschleunigung dieses
Projekts auf den Tisch zu legen ich habe
diese Äußerung von Herrn Kollegen
kischer wahrgenommen allerdings habe ich
auch gelesen dass er sich später anders
geäußert hat jedenfalls sind diese
Äußerungen kein Hinderungsgrund für mich
den Bundesverkehrswegeplan umzusetzen
keine Nachfrage mehr habe ich verstanden
das beschleunigt das Verfahren dann
kommt jetzt der Kollege alt aus der
SPD-Fraktion als nächster Fragestellung
ja sehr geehrter Herr Minister wir haben
jetzt ja Thema berichtet wie sie in
beklagenswerten Zustand Schleusen und
Wasserstraßen übernommen haben oft geben
werden über die großen überein und
Neckar wir haben aber auch kleinere
Wasserstraßen zum Beispiel ist in meinem
Wahlkreis die Schleuse Diemitz mit
45.000 schleusenvorgänge
schleusungsvorgängen pro Jahr also die
Schleuse mit den äh der größten Zahl an
Vorgängen pro Jahr und es gibt auch jede
Zahl an eine gute Zahl an touristisch
genutzten Wasserstraßen in Gebieten wo
der Wassertourismus eine erhebliche
Bedeutung hat wenn Sie diese
Priorisierung jetzt vornehmen müssen der
knappen Mittel wie fließen diese
berechtigten touristischen Belange auch
im wirtschaftlichen Belange in diese
Priorisierung mit ein
ja Kollege wir wissen um auch die
touristische Bedeutung unserer
Wasserstraßen aus der Sicht des
Bundesministers für digitales und
Verkehr sind natürlich die logistischen
Leistungen unserer Wasserstraßen
prioritär aber gleichwohl sind wir immer
bemüht wenn es um Ausbaufragen geht auch
touristische Belange zu berücksichtigen
ich habe unlängst dann ein
Schiffshebewerk
einweihen können dass beeindruckend ist
und ein richtiger Touristen Magnet auch
und in solchen Fällen arbeiten wir dann
auch eng mit der kommunalen Ebene
zusammen weil wir uns natürlich auch
freuen wenn
Infrastrukturen nicht nur als Belastung
gesehen werden sondern insbesondere bei
der Binnenwasserstraße eben auch als
touristische Bereicherung also insofern
wir denken diese Dinge mit
sie dürfen noch eine Nachfrage stellen
ja vielen Dank ist ja durchaus auch im
Wirtschaftsfaktor also nicht nur eine
Bereicherung sondern wirklich viele
Arbeitsplätze die daran hängen inwiefern
Herr Minister es gab ja zum letzten im
letzten Haushalt zum ersten Mal einen
Titel extra für den Ausbau touristischer
Wasserstraßen nach recht kleinen Höhe
wie sehen Sie die Weiterentwicklung
dieses Titels in der mittelfristigen
finanzbedarfsplanung ja dieser Titel
bringt das zum Ausdruck was ich eben
gesagt habe und sie haben völlig recht
Herr Kollege dass natürlich immer
touristische
Attraktivitäten auch einen
wirtschaftlichen Faktor darstellen vor
allen Dingen in ländlichen Räumen das
sind das sehr wichtige Faktoren und
deswegen ist die Bundesregierung auch
mit einem entsprechenden Haushaltstitel
ausgestattet wir haben ein großes
Interesse daran dass wir diese
touristischen Ziele mit unseren
Infrastruktur Ausbauzielen immer in
Einklang bringen können das sind
optimale Bedingungen wenn sich wenn man
sich so ergänzt sofern freue ich mich
auch wenn dieser Haushaltstitel
wir sind immer noch beim Thema
Wasserstraßen ich habe eine Nachfrage
noch des Kollegen Seidler
vielen Dank Herr Minister
sie ich bin übrigens sehr froh über die
Frage von der Kollegin Martin denn sie
spricht ja ein wichtiges Thema an die
Wasserstraßen und es wurde eben auch
gesagt dass es sich leider bei ihrem
Haushalt in diesem Bereich um eine
deutliche Unterdeckung eine signifikante
und der Deckung im Bereich Wasserstraße
handelt deshalb ist die Frage an Sie
erwarten sie denn in den kommenden
Jahren einen Anstieg des itars in ihrem
Haushalt um diesen zusätzlichen
Finanzbedarf dann auch zu decken den sie
eben selbst angesprochen haben und wenn
sie jetzt eben Priorisierungen
angesprochen haben auch eine direkte
Frage wo steht denn der
Nord-Ostsee-Kanal bei Ihnen auf der
Prioritätenliste
also Herr Kollege ich sehe dass die
Wasserstraße für uns so wichtig ist dass
wir es uns nicht leisten können dass wir
in unseren Ausbauzielen und auch
sanierungszielen hier aus finanziellen
Gründen hinter unseren Möglichkeiten
bleiben deswegen
strebe ich schon bei diesem Haushalt
eine gute Lösung an und bin auch im
entsprechenden Dialog wir versuchen auch
mit den vorhandenen Haushaltsmitteln
das zu erreichen was wir erreichen
müssen und der Nord-Ostsee-Kanal ist von
überragender Bedeutung und steht
deswegen bei mir ganz oben er ist auch
sehr wichtig um CO2 einzusparen und
damit kommt dem Nord-Ostsee-Kanal eine
besondere Bedeutung in vielerlei
Hinsicht zu das ist eine
Infrastruktur auf die wir stolz sein
können und die wir brauchen und die auch
voll in die Zeit passt
ich habe jetzt immer noch drei zu den
Wasserstraßen wenn diese drei nur eine
Nachfrage stellen würden mit einer
Antwort dann würde ich dir jetzt noch
machen und dann würde ich weitergehen in
die nächsten zuerst Herr Brandner aus
der afd-fraktion
ja nur eine Nachfrage ist knüpft an an
die erste Nachfrage der
hauptfragestellerin Martin da ging es ja
um die Frage der
Fachkräftegewinnung im Bereich der des
Wasser und Wasserstraßen und
schifffahrtsstraßenbaus jetzt sind ja
sozusagen um das Wort hier mal zu
bemühen die Schleusen für die Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung seit 2015 offen Millionen
Menschen sind nach Deutschland geströmt
wenn man der Propaganda folgt waren da
auch millionenfacharbeiter drunter
deshalb mal meine Frage konkret in den
Wasser und Schifffahrtsbereich wie ist
die Quote derjenigen die seit 2015 an
Fachkräften zu uns gekommen sind wie
hoch ist die Beschäftigungsquote in etwa
in diesem Bereich
Herr Kollege die Bundesregierung tut
alles um die
Berufe die wir im Bereich der Wasser-
und Schifffahrtsverwaltung haben
bekannter zu machen oft ist es so dass
diese Berufe auch gar nicht jedem
bekannt sind etwa der Wasserbauer ist
ein Beruf der unglaublich chancenreich
ist weil man eine Vielzahl von
Fähigkeiten und Kompetenzen erlernt ein
wirkliches Multitalent im handwerklichen
Bereich ist der Wasserbauer und ich habe
mir selbst viel Zeit genommen um mit
Azubis zusammen zu sein zu verstehen
warum sie das machen um auch die
notwendigen Schlüsse daraus zu ziehen
wie wir diesen Beruf stärker bewerben
können und wir arbeiten auch im engen
Austausch mit unserer Jugendvertretung
an ganz konkreten Konzepten wie wir
Fachkräfte in Deutschland gewinnen und
uns sind natürlich alle Fachkräfte
herzlich willkommen ich kann Ihnen jetzt
diese diese Zahl die sie beten haben
nicht aus dem Stegreif liefern weil wir
können gerne ihnen da eine Aufstellung
zukommen lassen
vielen Dank nächste Frage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Kollege plus
ich wollte noch einmal zurückkommen auf
die neckarschleusen verstehe ich ihre
Ausführung richtig dass sie sich zum
Ausbau der neckarschleusen bekennen mit
allen vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen wie sie
der Deutsche Bundestag beschlossen hat
bitte antworten Sie mit ja oder nein
ich habe schon darauf geantwortet ich
bin für den Ausbau der neckarschleusen
und muss trotzdem immer wieder an der
Stelle sagen dass es niemand hilft wenn
man an einer Ausbau der neckarschleusen
arbeitet und dabei vergisst die
Schleusentore zu ertüchtigen und damit
der neckarschifffahrt ein Risiko schafft
dass jederzeit eingestellt werden muss
weil Schleusentore ausfallen und
deswegen
muss ich prioritär mich mit der
Sanierung von Schleusentoren befassen
das hätten andere ehrlich gesagt auch
tun können aber ja ich bin für den
Ausbau
ich schließe jetzt auch mit dem letzten
Nachfrage dieses Schleusen der Kollege
aus der SPD-Fraktion Uwe Schmidt
frau Präsidentin recht schönen danke es
geht nicht um Schleusen auch wenn ich
nur ein Facharbeiter und Gesellenbrief
habe also frage ich jetzt mal in
Richtung der seewärtigen Anbindung der
deutschen großen Seehäfen die wir haben
Herr Minister sie wissen ja wir haben
sehr lange Planungsverfahren und Sie
haben ja eben an der Stelle auch
Stellung dazu bereits bezogen 19 Jahre
fast für die Elbe jetzt eine Umsetzung
in 18 Monaten immer wieder diese
unendlich lange auch auf der Außenweser
diese wichtigen Infrastrukturmaßnahmen
die Umsetzung der politischen
Entscheidungen die sich teilweise über
Jahrzehnte das kennen sie aus anderen
Genehmigungsverfahren auch aber auch sie
haben eben darüber hinaus angerissen die
Akquise der Fachkräfte aus der maritimen
Wirtschaft wenn wir sehen dass sie kaum
noch einen Zulauf aus den aus der
deutschen nautischen Branche bekommen
für ihre jeweiligen Häuser die Sie
brauchen um diese großen
Infrastrukturprojekte die sie eben
angesprochen haben dementsprechend auf
dem Weg zu bringen wie wollen Sie
gemeinsam mit uns dahin gehen in Zukunft
so gestalten dass wir deutlich schneller
aber auch deutlich besser in der
Umsetzung werden
Herr Kollege wir haben ja was
Verfahrensbeschleunigung angeht
planungsbeschleunigung angeht einiges
schon gemacht und bringen noch einiges
auf dem Weg mit einem neuen
planungsbeschleunigungspaket in diesem
Jahr
insgesamt brauchen wir für unsere Häfen
eine nationale hafenstrategie an die wir
an der wir arbeiten und in so eine
Strategie muss natürlich auch Fragen der
Fachkräftegewinnung mit einbezogen
werden die Häfen sind Infrastrukturen
von überragender Bedeutung und ich kann
nur sagen allen muss klar sein der
jetzigen Situation können wir dankbar
sein dass wir eine so gute Infrastruktur
haben wie wir sie haben
wie versorgen mit LNG und all die Dinge
setzen gute hafenanwendungen voraus und
deswegen spielt die hafenstrategie eine
eine wichtige sehr wichtige Rolle bei
mir im Haus
vielen Dank ich gehe über zu den
angemeldeten Fragen jetzt ist aus der
afd-fraktion nächster Fragesteller
Kollege Wiehle
ja frau Präsidentin Herr Minister vielen
Dank für das Wort
Herr Minister sie haben eingangs das 9
euro-ticket in hohen Tönen gelobt aber
muss auch wissen dass dieses neun Euro
Ticket die Bahn und ihre Mitarbeiter
stark überlastet hat natürlich haben das
viele ausprobiert und den Rabatt
mitgenommen aber es gab auch einen
kräftigen Rückgang des Ticketverkaufs
vom Juni bis zum August und das ist
gelitten hat unter der Maßnahme auch die
Busbranche jetzt möchten Sie mit einem
49 euro-ticket weitermachen und wieder
Fahrausweise großzügig mit Steuergeld
subventionieren jetzt habe ich Fragen an
sie
zunächst mal Herr Minister was sagen sie
den Menschen die auf dem Land draußen
leben wo vielleicht zweimal täglichen
Bus fährt die bezahlen dieses Geschenk
auch mit ihren Steuergeldern aber sie
haben davon nichts
der zweite Punkt was sagen Sie Herr
Minister den Busunternehmen den sie
schon wieder eine staatlich
subventionierte Konkurrenz
entgegenstellen und zuletzt nur eine
Frage sagen sie eigentlich das ist eine
also ich versuche es mal als Kombination
was sagen Sie dem Bundesrechnungshof der
jüngst wieder deutlich gemacht hat dass
der Nahverkehr Ländersache ist
ich sage den Menschen im ländlichen Raum
dass sie nicht denjenigen glauben sollen
die behaupten dass Ihnen dieses Ticket
nichts bräuchte
die Wahrheit ist nämlich dass die
öpnv-tickets im ländlichen Raum so teuer
sind die Einzelfahrscheine so teuer sind
und die monatsfahrkarten so teuer sind
dass es einen prohibitiven Charakter hat
und man deswegen nicht erwarten kann
dass die Leute den ÖPNV nutzen wenn man
Einzelfahrscheine über 10 € anbietet
oder Monatskarten für 300 € oder mehr
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir an
diese Menschen gerade im ländlichen Raum
denken und natürlich haben die Menschen
den vollen vereinfachungseffekt und
natürlich können die Menschen auch
intermodell des Ticket nutzen man muss
ja nicht mit dem ÖPNV von zu Hause
losfahren wenn man dieses Ticket nutzt
man kann ja auch eine Etappe mit dem
Ticket machen und deswegen ist das nicht
wahr dass das im ländlichen Raum nichts
bringt die Entlastungswirkung bei diesem
Ticket ist im ländlichen Raum ein
deutlich höher als im urbanen Raum
vielleicht können Sie meine Antwort
mitnehmen und den Leuten das dann auch
so sagen und die zweite Frage mit dem
Busunternehmen sind wir in einem engen
Austausch um sie mit einzubeziehen wir
wollen natürlich ein gutes Gesamtkonzept
und die dritte Frage dem
Bundesrechnungshof sage ich dass ich
seinen Auftrag sehr ernst nehme und
deshalb im Februar schon die
Verkehrsministerkonferenz gebeten habe
eine Arbeitsgruppe einzusetzen um diese
Finanzierungsfragen zu klären das
Zwischenergebnis dieser Arbeitsgruppe
wurde jetzt vorgelegt innerhalb von
wenigen Monaten wir konnten das oder die
Länder konnten das nicht aufrufen bei
der Verkehrsministerkonferenz in
Bremerhaven so dass es jetzt in einer
Sonderkonferenz beraten werden wird und
damit arbeiten wir auch den
Arbeitsauftrag des Bundesrechnungshof ab
ich bin mit einem in einem engen
Austausch mit dem Rechnungshof und wie
gesagt nehme die Kritik sehr ernst und
möchte diese Fragen klären
vielen Dank sie hatten eigentlich schon
drei Fragen Herr Wieler
eine ganz kurze nein nein eine kurze
Nachfrage frau Präsidentin wenn Sie
erlauben Herr Minister sie haben gerade
schon das 49 Euro Ticket so habe ich es
verstanden und die Zusammenarbeit mit
den Ländern angesprochen sie geben jetzt
gemeinsam mit den Ländern wieder eine
Milliardensumme aus aber auch dieses
Geld kann man ja nur einmal ausgeben
also darf ich fragen was sagen sie denn
Leuten die auf den Ausbau der
überlasteten Bahnstrecken warten auf die
Renovierung von Bahnhöfen oder ein
besseren Takt bei ihrem Bus und das
jetzt nicht bekommen weil dafür dann das
Geld fehlt
ich sage den Leuten dass das
nachfolge-ticket für das 9 Euro Ticket
keine Auswirkungen auf den aus auf
unserer Ausbauziele bei der china hat
wir werden selbstverständlich den ÖPNV
weiter ausbauen weil wir ihn brauchen
aber gleichzeitig vereinfachen wir den
ÖPNV machen es attraktiver ihn zu nutzen
denn es macht ja keinen Sinn Angebote zu
machen und sie dann so kompliziert zu
gestalten mit warmen Systemen unendlich
vielen tarifsystemen ticketsystemen wir
haben zwei Milliarden Euro
Vertriebskosten für ÖPNV Tickets in
Deutschland sie mögen das richtig finden
und so belassen wir wollen das ändern
weil wir uns dem Fortschritt
verpflichtet fühlen in unserem Land
ich habe zum Thema 9 euro-ticket
Nachfolge Ticket noch eine Nachfrage aus
der FDP-Fraktion der Kollege lenders
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundesminister das 9 Euro Ticket und
sein Nachfolger sollte jetzt mit
Sicherheit ab spätestens jetzt auch
ihren Namen tragen also sprich das
Wissen Ticket ist die nachhaltigste öpf
öpnv-reform die wir uns ja seit Jahren
denken können es ist unkompliziert das
ist für die für die Menschen einen
digitales Angebot aber welche Schritte
müssen von Seiten der Länder denn jetzt
unternommen werden um die regionalen
Verkehrsverbünde denn jetzt auch dann
entsprechend anzupassen was ist denn aus
ihrer Sicht jetzt notwendig seitens der
Länder um nachhaltig daraus auch ein
Erfolg zu machen
ja Herr Kollege lenders wir haben die
den einen Zeitplan gewählt der bisher
voll eingehalten wurde wir wollten im
September eine Arbeitsgruppe die einen
Beschluss auf der
Verkehrsministerkonferenz in Bremerhaven
vorbereitet dieser Beschluss wurde jetzt
gefasst wir haben eine Einigung zwischen
Bund und Ländern erzielt das Tickets
soll für 49 Euro auf den
angeboten werden es soll papierlos sein
so dass es auch entsprechend Daten
generieren kann und wir damit besser
planen können präziser planen können das
muss jetzt alles mit den
Verkehrsverbünden abgestimmt werden
diese Arbeiten laufen weil wir keine
Verzögerung erreichen wollen und am Ende
schaffen wir mit diesem Ticket einen
riesigen vereinfachungsschritt und die
Vorstellung dass man in Deutschland mit
einem Ticket überall die öpnv-strukturen
nutzen kann das ist etwas was die
Menschen wirklich begeistert hat und was
auch wahrscheinlich die größere Form im
ÖPNV in Deutschland darstellen und ich
bin sehr sicher dass wir damit auch
Vertriebskosten einsparen können die wir
nutzen werden um den Ausbau
voranzutreiben aber wir brauchen
natürlich auch andere Infrastrukturen
etwa wenn es um den Umstieg von dem Auto
oder dem E-Bike auf den Zug geht dann
brauchen wir andere Infrastrukturen am
Bahnhof und diese zustandardisieren
gemeinsam auch zu finanzieren das ist
das Ziel dass die Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit den Ländern vertritt und
verfolgt und Taktgeber sind wir dabei
ich habe jetzt als wenn sie keine Nerven
mehr hat sich hingesetzt Nachfrage
Erstellen von dann der Kollege Kröber
aus der SPD-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister
gehe ich recht in der Annahme dass viele
Kundinnen und Kunden
bereits im Juni und insbesondere Ende
Mai gleich drei Tickets auf einmal
gekauft haben und womöglich deshalb die
Verkaufszahlen im Juni hör waren als das
im Juli der Fall ist und die zweite
Frage wäre ob sie die Auffassung teilen
das insbesondere Menschen und Familien
mit sehr niedrigen Einkommen durch das
Ticket endlich die Chance hatten auch
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr deutlich
besser zu nutzen
zur ersten Frage das Ihre Frage klingt
plausibel ich würde aber gerne bevor ich
sie beantworte einmal die die Fachleute
befragen würde in diese Frage
nachliefern ob es daran liegt aber
wahrscheinlich ist es so ich habe aber
keine positive Kenntnis davon deswegen
liefere ich Ihnen das nach die zweite
Frage sie haben völlig Recht die dieses
besonders attraktive Angebot im Sommer
nur 9 € war ja als Entlastung gedacht
und es hat viele Menschen neue
mobilitätsmöglichkeiten eröffnet und es
hat auch viel Menschen die Hürde
genommen einfach mal den ÖPNV
auszuprobieren auch die zeitliche
Befristung war sicherlich auch ein Punkt
wo die Leute gesagt haben das lasse ich
mir nicht entgehen jetzt probiere ich es
aus und die Rückmeldungen die wir
bekommen haben waren fulminant Menschen
die mehr Teilhabe verspürt haben die
auch vieles erlebt haben in Deutschland
auch Seniorinnen und Senioren die auch
längere Strecken zurückgelegt haben die
die und erlebt haben ÖPNV funktioniert
auch junge Menschen die vielleicht auf
dem Land begeistert sind weil sie gerade
einen Führerschein gemacht haben die
trotzdem gesagt haben da kann ich auch
mobil sein ohne dass ich CO2 emittiere
die Rückmeldungen die wir bekommen haben
sind eine Reihe rührender Geschichten
und deswegen ist das insgesamt ein
wirklich großer Erfolg gewesen und das
war am Ende sicherlich auch der Grund
warum die Verkehrsministerkonferenz
gesagt hat ja wir unterstützen das an
Sinn des Bundes das fortzusetzen
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt gerade eine Wortmeldung
zur Geschäftsordnung bekommen von dem
Herrn Lutze aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
ich würde Sie bitten einmal
vorzutragen
ja vielen Dank Frau Vorsitzende ich
hatte eigentlich gesagt dass ich das
keine nach dem Punkt machen kann aber
ich kann so jetzt machen
der Tagesordnungspunkt lautet Befragung
der Bundesregierung wir haben jetzt fast
eine Stunde rum
und der Geschäftsordnung sind ja relativ
klar die Spielregeln geklärt dass eben
sehr viel offen ist ich stelle nur fest
dass innerhalb dieser einen Stunde es
offensichtlich meiner Fraktion aber
möglicherweise auch mehreren anderen
Fraktionen nicht möglich ist Fragen an
die Bundesregierung zu stellen da unsere
Fragen die wir hatten explizit nicht zum
Beispiel nicht zu Wasserstraßen nicht zu
9 euro-ticket nicht zu verkehren Energie
ging und ich möchte einfach mal hier an
der Stelle klipp und klar auch für meine
Fraktion sagen es müssen Regeln gefunden
werden das zumindest jede Fraktion eine
Frage stellen kann die sie selbst
gewählt hat vom Thema ansonsten machen
wir uns das hier ad absurdum
nein ich mache keine es war ein anderes
keine Debatte ich mache jetzt folgenden
Vorschlag erstens dass wir laut
Geschäftsordnung noch jetzt eine
Viertelstunde verlängern können das
würde ich jetzt auch tun das Thema
generell Fragestunde befrage ist auch
Thema im Geschäftsordnungsausschuss
insofern würde ich auch Ihren Antrag und
die Frage stelle die sie ja gerade
eingebracht haben dass wir uns damit
noch mal befassen wie die Fragestunden
ablaufen auch noch mal in diese
geschäftsordnungsausschussdebatte geben
und sicherlich ist aus der Ältestenrat
das Gremium wo wir dieses Format nochmal
besprechen können ich gebe Ihnen
vollkommen recht deswegen die
Viertelstunde hängen wir jetzt auf jeden
Fall dran so dass wir alle noch mal
einmal mit bei den anderen Fraktionen
durchkommen und Nachfragen lasse ich
dann jetzt auch nur noch zu
eine einzige
es ist schwierig weil ansonsten haben
sich ja alle Fraktionen letztendlich
jetzt gerade auch beteiligt aber ich
sehe ein dass natürlich auch die nicht
zum Thema passende Fragen gestellt
werden sollten ich gehe jetzt weiter in
der Reihenfolge obwohl ich gerade zu dem
Thema Ticket noch weitere Nachfragen
hatte aber aufgrund dieses Antrags würde
ich jetzt in die Reihenfolge noch mal
der angemeldeten Fragesteller gehen und
ich bitte auch um Verständnis
doch
er hat ja nur ein Hinweis gegeben er
bittet darum dass wir in Zukunft uns mit
diesem Format noch beschäftigen das habe
ich jetzt aufgenommen und den Rest
können wir gerne morgen im Ältestenrat
miteinander besprechen ich gehe jetzt in
der Fragestunde weiter wer ich habe sie
eine Viertelstunde verlängert und die
nächste Frage in der Reihenfolge stellt
die
Kollegin slawick aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister Wissing der
Sommer 2022 war der heißeste seit Beginn
der Wetteraufzeichnung in Europa
schätzungsweise sind 100.000 Menschen in
Europa an den Folgen der Hitze gestorben
das waren mehr als 2003 bei der letzten
großen Hitzewelle Deutschland gehört
auch zu den Ländern mit der größten
historischen Verantwortung in der
Klimakrise gleichzeitig hat Deutschland
im letzten Jahr seine Klimaziele gemäß
Klimaschutzgesetz das infolge des
Urteils vom Bundesverfassungsgericht
nachgeschärft wurde gerissen auch dieses
Jahr hat das Verkehrsministerium keine
keinen Maßnahmenkatalog vorgelegt der
unsere Verringerung erreichen würde der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen hat die
Maßnahmen zerrissen und ich sage dazu
sich nichtmals mehr im Detail angeguckt
weil vom Urteil gekommen ist dass sie
vollkommen unzureichend sind wann wird
ihr Ministerium einen Maßnahmenkatalog
vorlegen der in im Einklang mit der
Einhaltung der deutschen Klimaziele ist
vielen Dank
ja Frau Kollegin es ist so dass die
das Deutschland die Klimaschutzziele
nach dem Klimaschutzgesetz im Jahr 2021
verfehlt hat im vergangenen Jahr wurden
drei Millionen Tonnen CO2 zu viel
ausgestoßen und nach der Systematik des
Gesetzes bin ich dann verpflichtet einen
Vorschlag zu machen wie diese drei
Millionen Tonnen kompensiert werden
können wir haben dann einen Vorschlag
unterbreitet den wir vom
Fraunhofer-Institut haben prüfen lassen
und die Wissenschaftler kommen zum
Ergebnis dass mit dem von mir
vorgelegten Maßnahmen 13 Millionen
Tonnen eingespart werden können so dass
wir den Vorgaben des klimaschutzgesetzes
damit genügen
die Bundesregierung hat
noch keine Zahlen über die das Jahr 2022
weil es nicht abgeschlossen ist wir
haben uns aber vorgenommen in diesem
Jahr ein Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm
vorzulegen weil wir ehrgeizigere
Klimaschutzziele haben als die
Vorgängerregierung
für die Vorlage dieses Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramms ist das
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz zuständig
und ich weiß aus Gesprächen mit Herrn
Kollegen Harbeck dass er
selbstverständlich noch in diesem Jahr
das Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm vorlegen
wird
und
dieses umfasst dann eine alle Sektoren
auch den Verkehr und selbstverständlich
unterbreiten wir im Rahmen des
Klimaschutz Sofortprogramms das
klimaschutzministers entsprechend
Vorschläge und selbstverständlich werden
die dann auch sobald er das vorlegt
öffentlich
bedauerlicherweise haben sie den Balken
nicht gesehen aber gefühlt schwarz
glaube ich jetzt sehr lang sie dürfen
noch eine Nachfrage stellen
alle wissenschaftlichen Bewertungen die
mir vorliegen bezüglich der Maßnahmen
die aktuell durch die Bundesregierung
diskutiert werden im Verkehrsbereich
sind nicht ausreichend sind sie als
verantwortlicher Minister für den
Verkehrsbereich darauf vorbereitet dass
es Klagen auch gegen die Bundesregierung
geben kann die auf die Einhaltung des
klimaschutzgesetzes pochen
wir sind als Bundesregierung Frau
Kollegin bestrebt so viel wie möglich
und so schnell wie möglich Klimaschutz
zu betreiben natürlich müssen wir dabei
auch die gegenwärtige Gesamtbelastung
der Bevölkerung berücksichtigen müssen
Maßnahmen finden die auf der Strecke hin
die Gesellschaft mobil halten genau wie
wir beispielsweise im Energiesektor
dafür sorgen müssen dass wir auch über
die Strecke der hin zur Klimaneutralität
eine Energieversorgung haben sie werden
mir Recht geben dass der Betrieb von
Kohlekraftwerken nicht zu CO2-Einsparung
führt aber es notwendig um
energieversorgungssicher zu stellen und
ähnliche Notwendigkeiten gibt es auch im
Bereich der Mobilität und die
berücksichtigen wir ohne dabei unsere
Klimaschutzziele zu vernachlässigen das
ist der Geist des Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramms das zuständige
Ministerium vorlegen wird
vielen Dank einen schönen guten
Nachmittag auch von meiner Seite auch an
die BesucherInnen Besucher auf den
Tribünen und die haben eine Nachfrage
von Herrn Brandner
die Nachfrage bezieht sich auf die
einleitenden Worte der
hauptfragestellerin dass wir im letzten
jahrhunderttausend oder hunderttausende
hitzetote zu beklagen haben und als
Deutschland zu den Ländern mit der
größten historischen Verantwortung für
die Klimakrise gehören der
emissionsanteil Deutschlands über CO2
liegt bei ungefähr aktuell glaube ich
einem Prozent jetzt haben Sie dem nicht
widersprochen teilen Sie die Auffassung
dass Deutschland die größte historische
Verantwortung unter anderem an den
hitzetoten als auch an der Klimakrise
trägt den gerade ihre
koalitionspartnerin der von sich gegeben
hat
Herr Kollege die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ist ein Land das sich einer
großen internationalen Verpflichtung
bewusst ist viele Technologien die die
Menschheit weitergebracht haben stammen
aus unserem Land darauf sind wir
einerseits stolz aber wir wollen auch in
Zukunft Technologien entwickeln die
weltweit zu einer Verbesserung der
Lebensgrundlagen und vor allen Dingen
auch zum Schutz natürlicher
Lebensgrundlagen bei tragen und deswegen
fühlen wir schon daraus eine besondere
Verpflichtung und wir sind ein weit
entwickelndes Land das sehr viel leisten
kann und dass wir Klimaschutz betreiben
müssen ist unbestritten und deswegen
wollen wir in Deutschland auch sehr viel
leisten und wollen natürlich auch
vorangehen im übrigen bringt uns das
auch sehr viel Ansehen international
[Applaus]
dann kommen wir zur nächsten
zum nächsten Fragesteller die Hauptfrage
ist der Kollege Thomas Lutze
ja vielen Dank ja wir sind ich habe
jetzt eine Frage zum Thema Tempolimit
werden das heute im
Verkehrsausschuss also Kirmes auf
Autobahn ich kenne die Position die sie
persönlich haben ich kenne ihre
Fraktionen ihre Partei meine beim
Mindestlohn ist das ja dann auch
irgendwann mal
anders geschieden worden als was sie
ursprünglich hatten deswegen geht meine
Frage jetzt aber in die Richtung dass
ich von Ihnen gerne mal wissen möchte
welchen Preis möglicherweise die
Einführung eines Tempolimits für unseren
Haushalt hätte ich finde überall nur die
Zahl dass man rund 1,9 Millionen Tonnen
CO2 einsparen könnte wenn man auf 130
gehen würde aber was würde es denn
kosten wenn wir Mehrheit hier dem Haus
vorausgesetzt ein Tempolimit von 130
km/h auf deutschen Autobahnen einführen
würden was hätten Sie für ein Aufwand
dadurch
also das kann ich Ihnen aus dem Stegreif
nicht beantworten jedenfalls spielt das
keiner Rolle bei der Beantwortung der
Frage ob die Bundesregierung eine solche
Maßnahme ergreift es gibt andere Gründe
warum wir das nicht tun wir haben uns
auf andere Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
verständigt und wir verfolgen
selbstverständlich als
Bundesregierung die Ziele des
Koalitionsvertrages das ist die
Grundlage unseres Regierungs Handelns
aber wenn es solche Zahlen gibt wir
prüfen das gerne mal liefern wir Ihnen
die
sie dürfen noch einmal nachfragen wenn
Sie möchten
das ist nicht der Fall ich sehe auch aus
den anderen Fraktionen keine
weitere Frage dazu dann können wir
fortfahren in der
Fragesteller Runde und das ist jetzt für
die FDP
nee erstmal für die FDP habe ich hier
bei mir der
Maximilian Funke Kaiser
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin lieber
Bundesminister kommen wir zum aus meiner
Sicht wichtigsten Geschäftsbereiche in
ihrem Haus nämlich zum Thema
Digitalisierung schade dass es bei den
Fragen aktuell noch nicht angeklungen
ist gut dass sie bei ihrer Ausführung zu
Beginn darauf hingewiesen haben mit der
digitalstrategie haben sie eine
schlüssige Strategie vorgelegt und zwar
zum ersten Mal eine schlüssige Strategie
vorgelegt wie wir die Digitalisierung in
diesem Land voranbringen und sie haben
klare Ziele und Wegmarken formuliert
damit nehmen sie auch als
digitalminister die anderen Ministerien
mit in die Pflicht meine Frage welche
nutzen welchen Nutzen hat dieses
Vorgehen für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und anhand welcher konkreten Dinge
werden wir nun merken dass
Digitalisierung endlich vorangeht
Herr Kollege Funke Kaiser wir werden mit
drei hebelprojekten Türen öffnen zu
räumen unbegrenzter digitaler
Möglichkeiten und diese hebelprojekte
sind nicht frühzeitig angegangen worden
wir tun das jetzt das ist zum einen sind
das die digitalen Identitäten die
Voraussetzung dafür sind dass man
überhaupt kommunizieren kann als Bürger
mit dem Staat und mit der Verwaltung und
zum anderen sind das auch Normungen und
Standards die bestimmen müssen wenn man
mit unterschiedlichen Standards arbeitet
und die Daten
setze nicht zusammenpassen dann kann man
nicht wirklich Digitalisierung
vorantreiben und natürlich spielt auch
die digitale Konnektivität eine große
Rolle und man sieht jetzt die Umsetzung
in konkreten Beispielen etwa mit dem
building Information modeling Portal
dass wir diese Tage freigeschaltet haben
wo klare Standards für building
Information modeling gesetzt werden das
ist erst die Voraussetzung dafür dass
wir überhaupt ab 2025 dann flächende zum
Beispiel den Bund digitales planen am
digitalen Zwilling einführen können
[Applaus]
einer nach
Frage vielen Dank sie haben es
angesprochen Digitalisierung ist auch
eine Gemeinschaftsaufgabe
deswegen nehmen sie auch die anderen
Ministerien mit in die Pflicht wie
wollen Sie das dann bewerkstelligen über
die wie stellen Sie das sicher dass auch
die anderen Häuser liefern und ihre
Hausaufgaben machen und wir haben eine
digitalstrategie sorgfältig abgestimmt
in der sich die einzelnen Ministerien
verpflichtet haben konkrete Projekte
umzusetzen und auch einen konkretes
Datum angegeben haben an dem sie sich
messen lassen wollen also es hat damit
jeder die Chance erfolgreich zu sein bei
seinen Versprechungen oder nicht das
glaube ich schon ein sehr ehrlicher Weg
den die Bundesregierung insgesamt
gegangen ist und natürlich wollen wir
alle erfolgreich sein gleichzeitig
halten wir da die Umsetzung im
kontinuierlichen Austausch nach und
denken Sie bitte an die Zeit und sichern
so dass wir unsere Zeitpläne erreichen
das ist
ja das hat ja gepasst dann habe ich eine
Nachfrage vom Kollegen Brandl
Herr Minister vielen Dank in ihrer
digitalstrategie ist ein zentrales
Element die digitale Identität und es
steht zu lesen des Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in Zukunft ihren Personalausweis
auf dem Smartphone speichern können
können sie interessierten Bürger in
einfachen Worten erklären welche
Schritte Sie dafür unternehmen müssen
welche App sie dafür installieren müssen
und ab wann es möglich ist herzlichen
Dank
die einfache digitalen Identität wird
federführend im Bundesinnenministerium
organisiert wichtig ist dass wir in
diesem Bereich
Rechtssicherheit schaffen und natürlich
auch Datensicherheit schaffen es muss
technisch so aufgesetzt sein dass die
Identifikation dass Bürgers der
BürgerInnen durch im Rahmen der
digitalen Kommunikation
zweifelsfrei möglich ist im analogen
machen wir das durch Vorlage eines
Personalausweises durch eine
Unterschrift das geht im digitalen nicht
weil wir sonst Medienbrüche haben und
mit der digitalen Identität schaffen wir
die Voraussetzung dass das Anmelden von
von Stellen von Anträgen das
Anmelden eines Wohnsitzes und vieles
mehr künftig möglich ist und deswegen
ist dieser Hebel der digitalen Identität
so wichtig wir stimmen das auch
europäisch selbstverständlich ab weil
das ist ja nicht nur ein nationaler
sondern ein internationaler Auftrag
und dann habe ich noch eine Nachfrage
vielen Dank ich habe auch eine Frage zu
den hebelprojekten in der
digitalstrategie eines davon ist ja auch
der Ausbau der digitalen Infrastruktur
das soll auch durch eine Verbesserung
der Datenlage erleichtert werden nämlich
insbesondere durch den Gigabit durch das
gigabit-grundbuch
das soll ein einheitlichen
Internetauftritt für Breitbandatlas für
infrastrukturatlas und
mobilfunkmonitoring machen es sollte bis
zum dritten Quartal 2022 kommen das ist
vorbei die Bundesnetzagentur ist dafür
zuständig hat mir geantwortet dass sie
nicht anfangen konnte weil sie keine
Ressourcen dafür hat in der
Haushaltsberatung wurde uns gesagt 20
Stellen wurden angemeldet aber noch
nicht bewilligt daher möchte ich sie
gerne Fragen Herr Minister bei einem
günstigsten Fall diese 20 Stellen
bewilligt werden muss man ja noch
ausschreiben einstellen anlernen bis
wann kann man denn dann mit dem Gigabit
Grundbuch rechnen und im ungünstigsten
Fall wenn es um Haushalt 2023 nicht
klappt wann kommt es dann
Frau Kollegin Domstadt Berg das
gigabit-buch ist enorm wichtig und es
muss über eine Strecke hinweg mit dem
Gigabit Ausbau entwickelt werden wir
wollen das gigabit-grundbuch so schnell
wie möglich haben und tun alles dafür
dass es nicht an Stellen scheitert oder
an Ausschreibungen scheitert wir
verfolgen dieses Projekt mit Nachdruck
und mit hoher Priorität
wann
ich werde Ihnen einen Zeitraum nach nach
nennen
vielen Dank dann kommen wir zum nächsten
angemeldeten Fragesteller dem Stefan
Seidler
Herr Minister wie Sie wissen lassen sich
durch die Digitalisierung auch die
Kapazitäten unseres Schienenverkehrs
deutlich erhöhen und die Fälle
letztlichkeit stark zudem übrigens auch
allerdings ist durch die Digitalisierung
der Schiene auch sind damit auch viele
finanzielle Kosten und erhebliche Kosten
verbunden ist es zutreffend dass die
Länder auf Strecken mit ausschließlichem
Regionalverkehr wie beispielsweise bei
mir im Norden zwischen Flensburg und
Kiel diese Investitionen alleine tragen
müssen und sie sprachen eben von den
Regionalisierungsmitteln könnten diese
vielleicht in Zukunft auch darüber denn
finanziert werden diese
digitalisierungsaufgaben die damit dann
zusammenhängen
also die Digitalisierung der Schiene ist
in der Tat Herr Kollege eine wichtige
Voraussetzung dass wir effizienter
werden und dass die Schiene auch mehr
Verkehr aufnehmen kann
das digitale System setzt voraus dass
sowohl in der Schiene entsprechende
Technik verbaut wird aber eben auch im
Fahrzeug selbst und deswegen können wir
digitale Schiene nur nutzen wenn alle
Züge die dort fahren im entsprechend
auch aufgerüstet sind die bisherige
Förderpraxis sieht vor dass wir oder die
bisherige
Finanzstruktur sieht vor dass wir in die
Schiene investieren und diejenigen die
Züge betreiben in die Züge investieren
das wird jetzt durch die Digitalisierung
etwas vermischt durch die neuen
Anforderungen da suchen wir nach
Konzepten aber unser Ziel ist dass
jedenfalls die Digitalisierung der
Schiene nicht an
Finanzfragen scheitert und wir werden
auch eine Verantwortung der Frage
deswegen müssen wie gehen wir mit
güterzugunternehmen um die ja mit zum
Teil geringer Marge arbeiten und die
aber auch zeitgleich diese Investitionen
tätigen müssen das suchen wir dann nach
Lösung
vielen Dank eine Nachfrage von Leon
Eckert
vielen Dank die Digitalisierung der
Schiene macht das Schienennetz noch
angreifbarer und gerade in Zeiten der
aktuellen sicherheitspolitischen Lage
ist das wichtig im Auge zu behalten
deswegen wollte ich sie fragen ob sie
gegen zum Schutz der der Schienen und
auch der Infrastruktur der Bahn
insgesamt nach der Konzeption zivile
Verteidigung ihren Part vorbereitet
haben dort wird es unter anderem genannt
dass man behelfsgruppen mobile
Stellwerke und geschützte
krisenkoordinierungsstellen einrichten
soll ist das bereits erfolgt oder kann
es sein dass auch schon die
Vorgängerregierung die Konzeption zivile
Verteidigung nur schleppend umgesetzt
hat in diesem Ressort
selbstverständlich bedeutet
Digitalisierung auch neue Anforderungen
im Sicherheitsbereich wenn wir digitale
Systeme nutzen müssen wir sie vor
Angriffen schützen für uns ist aber klar
dass wir wegen dieser Fragen nicht den
Weg eingeht schlagen können auf
Digitalisierung zu verzichten sondern
wir müssen diese Schutzaufgaben dieses
Sicherungsaufgaben ernst nehmen und das
tut die Bundesregierung ich habe in
meinem zuständigkeits beispielsweise bei
Zuständigkeitsbereich beispielsweise auf
die Sabotage die wir neulich erleben
mussten mit der Einrichtung einer
Stabstelle Infrastruktur Sicherheit
reagiert um da auch noch mal aufzurüsten
und ihre konkreten Fragen die Sie zu
einzelnen Systemen gestellt haben würden
wir Ihnen gerne nachreichen
und noch eine Nachfrage von Herrn
Brandner
ja auch zur kritischen Infrastruktur da
hatte ich in der vergangenen Woche die
Kollegin schwarze Löwer eine Sutter
gefragt wie das denn mit dem Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur wäre und da hat
sie geantwortet der Brandner sie wüssten
doch also ich müsste wissen dass das gar
keine Bundesaufgabe wäre sondern dass
der jeweilige Betreiber für den Schutz
der kritischen Infrastruktur zuständig
wäre also für Pipelines der
Pipeline-Betreiber für die Bahn die
Deutsche Bahn das ist der Bund damit gar
nichts zu tun hat die gesagt das ist
jetzt eine Woche her und jetzt hören wir
plötzlich ist die ganze Regierung in
Aufruhr und sagt huch da muss ich ja
doch irgendwie der Staat um die
kritische Infrastruktur um den Schutz
der kritischen Infrastruktur kümmern
also das ist AFD wirkt muss ich sagen
pur ich frage in den letzten Woche und
blitzartig handelt die Bundesregierung
dafür mal vielen Dank zunächst mal aber
konkret wie sieht das aus also ist das
tatsächlich jetzt so beabsichtigt dass
der Bund teilweise den Schutz durch die
Bundespolizei oder durch die Bundeswehr
übernimmt gibt's ja schon konkrete Pläne
also zunächst hat man ihnen eine
richtige Auskunft gegeben dass das in
der Betreiber Verantwortung liegt
insofern gibt es dann nichts zu
korrigieren entscheidend ist natürlich
dass wir als dort wo wir selbst
Infrastruktur Betreiber sind das bin ich
als als Verkehrsminister in vielen
Bereichen dass wir dort unsere eigenen
Sicherheitsstrukturen immer überprüfen
wir haben gute Sicherheitsstrukturen das
hat man bei dieser Sabotage auf die Bahn
gesehen das hat hervorragend
funktioniert wir konnten innerhalb von
zweieinhalb Stunden
notleitungen legen dem Flug der
Zugbetrieb wieder aufnehmen und konnten
noch am selben Tag abends eine
vollständige Reparatur der Sabotage
Handlungen vornehmen niemand ist zu
Schaden gekommen alle
Sicherheitsmechanismen haben gegriffen
dass zeigt wir sind gut aufgestellt
gleichzeitig muss man immer wieder neu
überlegen was bedeuten neue Zeiten für
die Sicherheitsanforderungen und darauf
reagiert die Bundesregierung aber nicht
im Aufruhr sondern mit sachlicher
Kompetenz und Gelassenheit
und
[Applaus]
letzte Frage des Kollegen Brandl
vielen Dank Herr Minister es geht um
kritische Infrastrukturen sehen Sie die
aktuellen Regelungen für die Sicherheit
kritischer Infrastrukturen von privaten
Betreibern als ausreichend an oder
halten Sie es für notwendig dass wir
mehr tun auch an gesetzlichen Regelungen
zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit an
kritischen Infrastrukturen von privaten
Betreibern Stichwort beispielsweise
tiefseekabel
Herr Kollege Sicherheit und auch
Sicherheit von Infrastrukturen kann
niemals ein abgeschlossener Prozess sein
an dem man einen Haken macht sondern das
muss eine Daueraufgabe sein und
insbesondere bei Infrastrukturen bieten
ja ständig neu entwickelte Technologien
auch Möglichkeiten die Sicherheit zu
erhöhen deswegen ist es eine
Daueraufgabe der man sich zuwenden muss
wichtig ist dass man das mit hoher
Konzentration tut und dass man auch die
Kompetenzen die man an verschiedenen
Stellen in unserem Behörden hat dass man
die bündelt und nutzt das tut die
Bundesregierung und die
bundesinnenministerin
bereitet auch entsprechende gesetzliche
Maßnahmen vor um dort noch mal Dinge zu
erhöhen es sind auch es sind auch
Verstärkungen beispielsweise bei der
Schieneninfrastruktur von
kamera-kontrolle vorgesehen wir haben
heute wenn ich über die Schiene spreche
34.000 Kilometer Schiene haben dort
4.300 Sicherheitsleute der Bahn und 5500
Bundespolizisten und sind damit mit
einem engmaschigen Sicherheitssystem
aufgestellt und das wird ständig
überprüft und wo nötig wird das
feinjustiert noch weiter verschärft
vielen herzlichen Dank und damit beende
ich die
Befragung der Bundesregierung und rufe
die so diese Befragung hat ja ein
bisschen länger gedauert sie wurde
verlängert unter anderem weil es ja von
Thomas Lutzer aus der Linksfraktion hier
doch ein eine Anmerkung gab dass durch
die vielen Nachfragen zu einzelnen
Themenkomplexen man nicht so schnell
durchgekommen ist mit den vorab